* Piepen *
(Frauenstimme)
Sixteen push-ups to go.
Jeden Morgen macht er Push-ups.
Er ist nie länger als drei Nächte
an einem Ort.
Und er duscht ausschliesslich kalt.
(Flüsternd) Ah!
Weil er beruflich viel unterwegs ist,
hat er seine Wohnung aufgegeben.
Er schläft im Hotel
oder bei Freunden.
Er besitzt nur noch 64 Gegenstände.
Cédric Waldburger ist Minimalist.
Das ist alles, was ich habe, ja.
Alles Materielle, das ich besitze.
Also nebst dem Bankkonto?
Bankkonto, natürlich auch Firmen,
verschiedene Projekte,
das sind auch Anteile,
die man besitzt.
Aber alles, was man anfassen kann,
ist auf dem Bett oder ich trage es.
Ich glaube, es geht stark darum,
dass man sich bewusst wird:
Was ist mir wichtig im Leben
und was nicht?
Und dass man das
konsequent umsetzt.
Das sieht man bei mir stark
im Bereich der Gegenstände,
die ich besitze,
wie konsequent ich das umsetze.
Aber ich versuche es in
vielen anderen Lebensbereichen auch
und sehr konsequent
Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Es ist schon ein Trend. Viele Leute
denken: "einfacher ist besser",
oder "ich möchte ich nicht
mit Dingen herumschlagen".
* Energiegeladene Rhythmen *
Minimalist Waldburger
entwickelt Apps,
um sein Leben und das aller anderen
zu optimieren.
Er ist international an verschiedenen
Firmen und Projekten beteiligt.
Darum ist er ständig unterwegs.
Sein Büro ist jeweils dort,
wo es Internet gibt.
Morning, guys!
- Morning!
Let's jump right into
our weekly call. I feel refreshed.
Fast alle seine Mitarbeiter
leben in Osteuropa.
Er hat sie zwar mit einer
selbst entwickelten App eingestellt,
kennt aber noch nicht alle
persönlich.
Wir haben sehr viel Kontakt.
Versteht man unter persönlich
in der echten Welt,
fehlt mir das schon ab und zu.
Es wäre schön, mit den Mitarbeitern
abends was trinken zu gehen.
Wir holen das sehr bewusst nach
in den Retreats,
wenn wir uns alle drei Monate
in der echten Welt treffen.
Da konzentrieren wir uns voll
auf Teambildung, lernen uns kennen.
Selim Tolga ist Minimalist.
Sein Glück
ist der Überfluss der andern.
Meine Mission ist, dass die Leute
sich wieder freier fühlen können,
leichter, leichter durchs Leben
gehen können, ohne Ballast,
mit dem Fokus auf das Wesentliche.
Wer unter einem Zuviel leidet,
meldet sich bei ihm.
Er ist Aufräumcoach.
Sie brauchen mich, weil sie
viel Material angesammelt haben.
Meist über viele, viele Jahre.
Es ist schwierig, loszulassen.
Dafür gibt es verschiedene Gründe.
Dann holen sie eben mich.
Dann ist es einfacher, loszulassen.
Und es macht auch mehr Spass,
gemeinsam aufzuräumen.
Wir sind hier in der Schweiz.
Der Schweizer ist bezüglich
Aufräumen sehr zurückhaltend.
Und auch schüchtern,
man outet sich nicht gerne.
Deshalb muss all das
sehr diskret ablaufen
und ich habe auch keine Aufschrift
auf dem Auto oder der Jacke.
Alles läuft sehr diskret ab,
was auch geschätzt wird.
Hallo, Ute.
- Hallo, Selim!
So!
- Jetzt haben wir aber was vor!
Hast du gut geschlafen?
- Ja.
Garderobe. - Da kann ich schon
einen Blick in den Schrank werfen.
Schau mal!
Ich habe schon Platz gemacht.
Die Weihnachtsdeko? Ein Objekt,
das man einmal im Jahr braucht.
Brauchst du sie einmal im Jahr?
- Also, sicher!
Okay, das ist gut. - Es ist nicht
jedes zweite Jahr Weihnacht.
Aber man könnte es vielleicht auch
auf die Winde tun.
Wäre das besser? - Ja, gut.
- Das fängt ja gut an!
Wollen wir eine Runde machen?
- Ja, mach eine Runde.
Jetzt zeige ich dir die Wohnung.
- Ja, gehen wir in die Wohnung.
Schau mal! Also ...
- Ich war ja schon einmal hier.
Ja, kurz.
- Hast du nicht extra aufgeräumt?
Jetzt, da ich gekommen bin.
- Nein. - Super! Gut so.
Ich räume ja mit dir auf,
das ist ja der Punkt. - Genau.
Weil ich es alleine nicht kann.
Weil mir alles leidtut,
was ich wegwerfe.
Wenn du sagst "Das ist Mist",
fällt es mir vielleicht leichter.
Also, wenn du dir die Wohnung,
wie sie jetzt ist, mit allen Räumen,
gedanklich visualisierst,
was würdest du dir erhoffen,
wie es allgemein aussehen würde?
Ich erhoffe mir mehr Klarheit.
- Mehr Klarheit.
Eine Reduktion.
Geschirr, Bücher ...
Bilder, Lampen ...
Ich habe von allem etwas zu viel.
Aber meine Tochter will gar nichts.
Sie mag es klar und clean - wie du.
Ja.
- Gut.
Wollen wir loslegen?
- Wow! Selim!
Das Wichtigste ist,
einfach irgendwo anzufangen.
Dann kommt man in den Fluss.
- Ist das wahr?
Ja. Wir gehen jetzt einfach mal
in den Paper Room. - Gut.
Los geht's!
Papier, Papier. Wenn's hier ...
Hier würde es gut brennen.
Das war immer so eine Notlösung.
Jetzt muss dieser Tisch hierher
und hier hatte es keinen Platz.
Was ist z.B. in dieser Box?
Weisst du das noch?
Die sind leer.
- Super, schon etwas aufgeräumt!
Also. Leere Schachteln
müssen nicht sein, gell?
Okay.
- Aber sie sind schön, schau mal.
Ich vertraue ihm.
Ich denke,
wir geben zusammen das weg, was ...
... was weg muss.
- Wieso können Sie das nicht allein?
Ich hörte einen Vortrag von ihm.
Er hat so toll erzählt,
wie er das organisiert und managt.
Da dachte ich:
wieso nicht einer, der mir hilft?
Andere nehmen sich einen Psychiater
und ich so einen Ordnungscoach.
Es ist sehr typisch. Es kontaktieren
mich sehr unterschiedliche Leute.
Meist sind es Leute,
die zu viel angesammelt haben.
Das hat sich über mehrere Jahre
kumuliert. - Jahrzehnte.
Jahrzehnte sogar.
Es sammelt sich an.
Muss ich die jetzt alle wegwerfen?
Nein, das nicht. - Das nicht.
- Aber z.B. die besten behalten.
Die sind ja noch ungebraucht.
Alle sind die besten.
Du darfst einfach nie mehr
in deinem Leben Bleistifte kaufen.
Ja. Schau mal!
Ich sehe jetzt schon, dass ich ...
(Seufzend) ... nicht so viele
Bleistifte brauche.
Welches sind deine liebsten
Bleistifte hier drin?
Die mit dem Gummi hinten.
Wie viele darf ich rausnehmen?
Hier ist ja der Gummi
gar nicht mehr dran.
Weg damit, weg!
- Gib mir das, was weggeht!
Kuros ist viereinhalb.
Dem schenke ich das.
Also. Blau?
- Ui, guck mal!
Ein ganzes Säcklein Kugelschreiber.
Schau mal: schöne.
Oder in die Brockenstube? - Nein,
das geben wir nicht dem Jungen.
So, jetzt hatten wir doch
einen guten Anfang.
Super Anfang.
- Schauen wir dieses Gestell an!
Wenn man diese wegnimmt ... - Aber
vielleicht muss man sie wegwerfen.
Wie sieht es jetzt aus?
- Sehr schön. - Was stört noch?
Nix mehr.
- Das hier ist zum Durchschauen.
Man muss sich damit befassen,
es in die Hände nehmen, durchsehen,
dann kommen die Emotionen.
Man muss es im Kopf platzieren.
Es ist ein Prozess,
der nicht so schnell geht.
An der Zürcher Hochschule der Künste
ZHdK beschäftigt man sich
mit dem Thema Ordnung und Struktur.
Ganz dem Zeitgeist entsprechend
gibt es für Dozenten
keine fixen Arbeitsplätze.
Paolo Bianchi
ist Dozent für Querdenken.
Er tut sich schwer
mit einengenden Ordnungssystemen.
Die Vorgabe ist,
dass wir alle unser Pult aufräumen,
im Gegensatz zu diesem Atelier,
damit es ein Arbeitsplatz ist,
an den sich andere wieder setzen
können.
Wie ein Stafettenlauf:
Wer gerade hier ist ...
Aber das Problem ist: Wie geht das?
Ich brauche ja ...
Wir sind ja beim Thema Ordnung.
Ich brauche einen Ordner.
Und ich habe drei, vier Ordner
neben mir, die noch leer sind.
Ich kriege sie einfach nicht voll.
Denn die Papiere, Unterlagen,
die ich habe, sind nicht A4,
nicht genormt, sie sind
irgendwie grösser oder dicker.
Sie widerstreben sich
dem Ablagemechanismus.
Der Widerstand ist grösser,
obwohl das Gesetz vorgibt,
man müsse aufräumen.
Minimalist Waldburger besitzt
natürlich auch kein Auto mehr.
Sein bester Freund Fabian Villiger
hingegen schon.
Mit ihm fährt er gerne mit.
Cédric Waldburger
hat einen Master in Elektrotechnik
und in der Schule
gehörte er immer zu den Besten.
Fabian war Pfadileiter
und der vier Jahre jüngere Cédric
ist ihm sofort aufgefallen.
Wir hatten eine tolle Gruppe.
Er war vif, gut
und damals schon schlau.
Er nahm einem
nicht jeden Quatsch ab.
Seine Mutter war jeweils froh,
wenn er vom Computer
wieder in den Wald kam.
Samstags warst du im Wald, abends
konntest du wieder am PC sitzen.
Mit zwölf war ich viel am PC.
Ich weiss nicht, ob Nerd oder nicht.
Aber ich merkte schon damals,
dass mir der Ausgleich guttut,
ab und zu in der Natur zu sein.
- Du wurdest dann auch Leiter.
Und ich wurde Stammleiter.
Wir machten Lager und merkten:
Man arbeitet gut zusammen.
Die Chemie stimmt,
es macht Spass.
Dann kam die Leidenschaft
für Websites.
Ich habe gestaltet,
Cédric hat programmiert.
Unser erstes Projekt war die Website
der Pfadi Rapperswil-Jona.
In diesem Zeitalter
waren Websites noch völlig neu.
Wie alt waren Sie da?
Ich ca. 14 und du ca. 18.
- Ja.
Wir sagten:
"Jetzt machen wir das, hobbymässig."
Fabian gab damals seinen Job auf,
sobald wir das Büro hatten.
Ich studierte tagsüber an der ETH,
abends klatschten wir ab.
Ich habe verarbeitet,
was Fabian tagsüber verkauft hat.
Besonders freute mich, wenn er etwas
verkaufte, von dem ich nicht wusste,
wie man es programmiert.
Dann wurden die Nächte länger.
Ihre damals gegründete Werbeagentur
beschäftigt heute
mehrere Mitarbeitende.
Cédric ist nicht mehr
operativ beteiligt.
Aber wenn er in der Schweiz ist,
benutzt er immer
das Büro der Agentur.
Villiger ist gerne Patron,
sesshaft und hasst es zu fliegen.
Im Geschäft gemeinsam erfolgreich,
könnten ihre Lebensstile
unterschiedlicher nicht sein.
Fabian besitzt wohl
etwas mehr als ich.
Wie viele Gegenstände haben Sie?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich habe keinen Plan! Mir würde auch
nie einfallen, das aufzuschreiben.
Er spinnt doch!
Er hat eine Liste mit 64 Dingen.
Nur schon die Idee,
alles aufzuschreiben!
Wenn ich alles ...
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Ich habe auch vieles,
das ich nie brauche.
Aber ich habe wohl schon mehr
als 64. Viel mehr!
Ich habe 1'064! Ich weiss nicht.
Was hat ein normaler Haushalt?
Schätzungsweise Zehntausend.
Ich koche auch gerne, da hast du
ja nur schon zehn Rüstmesser.
Ich kenne
kaum einen anderen Menschen,
der in seinem Leben so diszipliniert
ist - mit allem, was er tut.
Mit seinem Tagesablauf,
seinen Zielen: extrem diszipliniert.
Dafür versteht es Villiger
zu geniessen und freut sich,
dass er sich
eine grosse Wohnung leisten kann,
wo er mit seiner Frau lebt.
Waldburger ist derzeit Single. Und:
Er trinkt aus Prinzip
immer nur Wasser.
Merci.
- Bitte.
Sieht man jetzt Cédrics Lebensstil,
mit den 64 Dingen, minimalistisch,
aufs Wesentliche beschränkt,
ist das super schön.
In ein paar Jahren sagt Cédric
vielleicht, er möchte eine Familie.
Dann gibt es Kinder - mal schauen,
wie viel Spielzeug die dann haben.
Das geht dann nicht: "Nein,
jetzt hast du nur dieses Auto."
"Wenn du das andere möchtest,
tun wir dieses weg."
"Es gibt nur eines auf der Liste
meiner Gegenstände."
Das ist nicht ganz einfach.
Das, was ich diszipliniert
durchziehen möchte, ist,
dass ich mich immer konsequent
frage, was mich glücklich macht
und das auch verfolge.
Momentan heisst das:
möglichst viel Zeit in die
verschiedenen Projekte investieren,
möglichst frei sein,
von einem Tag auf den nächsten
den Kontinent wechseln können.
Darum habe ich momentan
so wenige Dinge, weil ich weiss:
Das dient einem Ziel,
das mich glücklich macht.
Eigentlich paradox.
Menschen, die sich viel leisten
können, leiden plötzlich darunter.
Für Cédric Waldburger ist das derzeit
alles, was er an Besitz braucht.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Weniger ist mehr.
Auch bei der Wohnfläche.
Dieses baubiologische Haus
ist nur 35 m2 gross.
Es besteht aus Holz und Lehm und
ist bis auf das Wasser energieautark.
Ein sog. Ökominihaus,
entwickelt von Tanja Schindler.
Sie lebt seit einigen Jahren
minimalistisch.
Es ist eigentlich
ein extrem schöner Prozess,
wenn man minimalistisch leben will -
aber kein einfacher.
Ich rate jedem,
sich dafür ganz viel Zeit zu geben:
Mindestens ein Jahr einplanen und es
schrittweise, langsam angehen.
Sich jedes Mal wieder an die neue
Situation von weniger Dingen,
z.B. im Kleiderschrank, gewöhnen,
bevor man
den nächsten Schritt macht.
Damit man eben keinen Frust
und keine Überforderung spürt.
Wenn man das langsam angeht
und seinen Geist mitwachsen lässt,
ist es jedes Mal eine extreme
Befreiung und eine Freude,
wenn man es geschafft hat.
Fünf Jahre stand ihr Haus in der Nähe
von Uster im Kanton Zürich.
Ein mega Kran.
Jetzt ist der Pachtvertrag fürs Land
abgelaufen und sie muss umziehen.
In ihrem Fall heisst das,
das ganze Haus reisefertig zu machen.
Es ist alles bereit, was?
Ihr Freund lebt in Altdorf
im Kanton Uri
und dort hat sie
einen Platz gefunden,
wo sie ihr Haus aufstellen darf.
Nein!
Ich habe nichts knacken gehört
oder so. Habt ihr etwas gehört?
Meine Nerven
würden das echt nicht oft aushalten.
Ihr 19 t schweres Zuhause
ist eigentlich dafür konzipiert,
dass man damit
den Standort wechseln kann.
Trotzdem ist der Umzug aufwändig.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen,
Minimalismus sei,
nur noch 100 Dinge zu haben.
Für mich heisst Minimalismus:
Nur noch die Dinge um einen herum
zu haben, die einem guttun.
Das ist für gewisse Leute
mehr als für andere.
Das ist individuell.
Für mich ist es nicht einfach ein
Beschränken auf eine gewisse Menge.
Das Vorgehen ist eigentlich
eine maximale Ausweitung
an Möglichkeiten,
an allem, was zur Verfügung steht,
von Mensch über Dinge über Konsum.
Und dann soll versucht werden,
eine Auswahl zu treffen.
Wir nennen das bei uns
eine Art Kuratieren,
ein Auswählen,
in Zusammenhang bringen oder so.
Vielleicht sind Minimalisten
wirklich Lebenskuratoren
oder Kuratoren des eigenen Ichs.
Kollegen, was?
- Ja.
Schreib "Kolleginnen"!
- "Kolleginnen".
Das könnte auch da drin sein, oder?
So schön! Schau mal! Das liebe ich.
Dinge, die verstreut sind, sollten
wenigstens mal am gleichen Ort sein.
Das gehört zum ...
Wir können auch noch eine Kiste
"Weiss noch nicht" machen.
Will ich nicht mehr.
Den schenke ich dir.
Aber den willst du wohl nicht.
Weg!
Das ist das Hochzeitsgeschirr
meiner Mutter.
Das brauchst du ab und zu
bei speziellen Anlässen. - Ja.
Was hast du in diesem Buffet seit
einem Jahr nicht mehr gebraucht?
Da gibt's
diesen wunderbaren Suppentopf.
Komm, gib den ins Brockenhaus!
* Sie lacht. *
Die behalte ich.
Die ins Brocki.
- Brocki.
Hätte ich echt nicht gedacht.
Aber stimmt es für dich?
- Ja, ja.
Noch vier Tage wird der Aufräumcoach
mit ihr weiterarbeiten.
Die Gabeln hier?
- Gabeln, ui ui ui.
Minimalist und Optimierer Waldburger
übernachtet gerne bei seinen Eltern,
wenn er in der Schweiz ist.
Seine Schwester
hat sich schon früh daran gewöhnt,
dass ihr Bruder einen speziellen
Umgang mit Dingen pflegt.
Er war nie einer,
der immer alles Neue wollte.
Das Typischste
war etwas ganz Einfaches:
Als Papa mal einen neuen
Badewannenstöpsel brachte,
fragte er: "Wieso,
der alte ist doch auch noch gut!"
Er wollte schon immer
nicht unbedingt Neues,
wenn das Alte noch okay war.
So war es eigentlich.
Ich hatte am Anfang Mühe damit,
als er anfing, sein Zimmer zu räumen
und über Dinge,
an denen ich emotional hing,
sagte, er brauche sie nicht mehr,
er komme ja nur noch
nach Hause zum Schlafen.
Da sagte ich: "Ist doch egal,
lass das doch in dem Schrank,
das stört ja niemanden."
Aber er sagte: "Nein, ich brauche es
nicht mehr, also gebe ich es weg."
Ich musste mich
am Anfang daran gewöhnen.
Erst dachte ich, er habe halt wieder
einen Spleen, wie ich das nenne.
Er hatte schon von klein auf
manchmal spezielle Ideen
und setzte sie extrem um.
Das begriff ich
am Anfang auch nicht recht.
Ich dachte immer: "Ja, ja, das
dauert nun einfach eine Weile."
Erst, als wir mehr darüber sprachen,
auch, als er anfing,
diese Dinge vorzutragen,
musste ich sagen: "Doch, er hat sich
das alles sehr gut überlegt
und macht das begründet."
Daher verstehe ich es nun auch.
Ich würde nie tauschen wollen,
könnte das nie.
Aber wir sind heute auch so weit,
dass wir bei vielem überlegen,
ob wir es brauchen oder nicht.
Ich könnte es mir nie vorstellen
mit so wenig Dingen.
Das wäre mir definitiv zu wenig.
Aber es spornt schon ein wenig an,
wie Heidi es sagte.
Bei gewissen Dingen
überlegt man es sich zweimal:
Brauche ich noch mal zwei Paar Hosen
oder noch ein paar Hemden?
Man kommt schon
mit wesentlich weniger aus.
Haben Sie den Eindruck,
dass er glücklich ist? - Ja, sehr.
Absolut.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Bei meinem Flug beginnt
das Boarding. Es geht nach Singapur.
Jetzt geht es nach Frankfurt.
Dann geht es für mich nach Indien
und dann Australien.
Gut anderthalb Mal um die Erde
innerhalb von drei, vier Wochen.
Mein 100. Flug dieses Jahr.
Ich trinke vor den Flügen immer viel
wegen der trockenen Luft,
um meinen Körper hydriert zu halten.
Mein Zuhause für die nächsten 8 Std.
Jetzt mache ich ein Nickerchen.
Es ist jetzt Mitternacht.
Ich bin am Flughafen Zürich.
Eines der Dinge, die ich hier
öfter mache: einchecken.
Flughafen Zürich. Und ...
Das Interessante hier ist,
dass man sieht:
In den letzten paar Jahren ist das
mein 255. Mal am Flughafen Zürich.
Tausende von Flugmeilen jährlich
sind alles andere als minimalistisch.
Ich bin mir dessen bewusst,
dass das nicht optimal ist.
Ich versuche, nicht einfach
wegen des Fliegens zu fliegen.
Vielleicht leiste ich
andererseits einen Beitrag,
indem ich nicht Dinge kaufe
und sie schnell wieder wegschmeisse.
Aber klar ist es nicht optimal.
Für die digitalen Nomaden
ist es normal geworden,
zwischen den Welten,
in denen die einen am Mangel leiden
und die anderen
den Überfluss beklagen,
hin und her zu pendeln.
Immer im Fokus:
die stete Steigerung
der Lebensqualität.
Cédric Waldburger will v.a.
die beste Version seiner selbst sein.
Das war das zweite Set.
Genau.
Ich brauche eine App, um jeden
Morgen mein Workout zu machen.
Ich sehe hier, wie viele Push-ups
ich im Jahr mache.
Dieses Jahr waren es ungefähr 8'500
Push-ups, im Schnitt 140 pro Tag.
Insgesamt verbrachte ich 9 1/2 Std.
mit Push-ups dieses Jahr.
Ich nutze die App
schon seit fünf Jahren.
Es ist noch spannend,
hier sieht man:
Ich habe mit dieser App allein
total schon 42'000 Push-ups gemacht.
Ich mag Push-ups sehr,
weil sie wenig Platz brauchen.
Und es bringt einen ins Schwitzen,
bringt einen weiter, macht fit.
Es ist alles komplett schwarz.
Das hat verschiedene Vorteile:
Es passt immer alles zusammen
und ich muss nur eine Wäsche
pro Woche machen.
Und ich muss eine Entscheidung
weniger fällen.
Wenn ich mich entscheide,
etwas zu kaufen,
muss ich nicht überlegen,
ob in rot, schwarz oder blau.
Der letzte Punkt ist eher praktisch:
Meist sind die Betten weiss bezogen
in Hotels und Apartments,
und Schwarzes verliert man nicht
so schnell auf weissen Betten
wie weisse T-Shirts oder Hemden.
Heute ist er in einem Hotel
in Armenien erwacht, in Eriwan.
Can you take a minute
and go through the expectations
we collected
at the beginning of the retreat.
Er gibt Anweisungen an sein Team,
das er gleich treffen wird.
Wie immer hat er
seinen ganzen Besitz bei sich.
Viermal im Jahr trifft er
irgendwo auf der Welt sein Team.
Es sind inzwischen
sieben Mitarbeiter.
Jeweils
in einem sog. Coworking Space,
einem gemieteten Büro.
Hey, guys.
Morning, guys!
Online hat er als Chef
jederzeit die Übersicht darüber,
woran seine Angestellten
gerade arbeiten.
These will be the e-mails
triggered from Mixpanel.
Bezahlt wird nur
sog. produktive Zeit.
Auch in seinen Firmen
geht es v.a. um Effizienzsteigerung.
Sendtask
ist eine Task-Management-App,
die es einem erlaubt, mit seinem
eigenen Team zusammenzuarbeiten,
aber auch mit seinen Kunden
und Suppliers, also Zulieferern
und Drittparteien. Auf eine viel
effizientere Art als per E-Mail.
Sein persönlicher Assistent Bojan
lebt in Moldawien
und organisiert von dort aus
das Leben seines Chefs.
Auch ihn trifft er
nur alle drei Monate:
Ich mag die Idee,
alles minimalistisch zu halten.
Man ist doch sehr mobil,
was bei ihm sehr wichtig ist,
bei seinem Lebensstil.
Ja, ich finde es
ziemlich interessant.
Sie haben Familie. Könnten Sie sich
das für sich auch vorstellen?
Auf keinen Fall.
Mit Kindern geht das ja nicht.
(Mann) Twelve, thirteen,
fourteen, fifteen ...
And - one!
Two! Three! Four! Five!
Disziplin und Selbstoptimierung
sind wichtige Werte
im Leben von Cédric Waldburger.
Sport ist Pflicht für sein Team -
genauso wie Ausflüge
in einen sog. Room Escape.
D.h., er lässt sich mit dem ganzen
Team in einen Raum einsperren,
z.B. einen dunklen, und nur wenn sie
gewisse Rätsel lösen,
können sie sich gemeinsam befreien.
Es gewinnt, wer am schnellsten ist.
Das nennt er effiziente Teambildung.
Fokussieren ist essenziell
für den Minimalisten.
Durchaus auch
mit unkonventioneller Methode:
Ich habe einen Spleen:
Ich geniesse es, einen Fön
mit warmer Luft laufen zu lassen
wenn ich mich konzentrieren muss.
Das kann Programmieren sein oder
Auswendiglernen, Sprachen lernen.
Oder jetzt auch hier,
wenn ich in einen Flow kommen möchte
und Dinge einfach niederschreibe,
meinen Kopf entleere.
Wenn es irgendwo,
wo ich bin, keinen Fön gibt,
lasse ich ein Audio-File
mit Föngeräusch laufen.
Es ist völlig gaga,
aber es funktioniert.
Und das von mir zu hören: Es muss ja
nicht immer alles Sinn machen.
Er hat sein Leben in zwölf Bereiche
wie Business, Sport, Freunde usw.
eingeteilt
und kontrolliert alle drei Monate,
ob er seine selbst gesteckten Ziele
erreicht hat.
Der Prozess läuft so ab,
dass ich mich hinsetze
und eine E-Mail schreibe,
die aus zwei Teilen besteht,
einem Rück- und einem Ausblick.
Im Rückblick schaue ich auf
die zwölf Lebensbereiche zurück
und stelle mir selber Fragen wie:
Wie fühle ich mich
in diesem Lebensbereich?
Ich versuche,
mit mir möglichst ehrlich zu sein.
Bin ich unendlich glücklich oder
gibt es Dinge, die mich stören?
Dann gibt es auch noch
detailliertere Fragen,
z.B. im Bereich Freunde:
Ich frage mich, mit welchen Leuten
ich am meisten Zeit verbrachte
in den letzten 90 Tagen, was ich von
ihnen lernen konnte und umgekehrt.
Und:
Sind es die richtigen fünf Leute?
Basierend auf diesem Rückblick
schreibe ich in einem zweiten Teil
dieser E-Mail einen Ausblick,
bei dem ich mir sehr konkret sage,
was ich in den Bereichen
ändern möchte.
Ich schicke das in die Zukunft,
also nutze einen Service,
der mir diese Mail
90 Tage später zurückschickt.
Also in 90 Tagen, wenn ich eine Mail
abschicke, bekomme ich die alte.
So habe ich schwarz auf weiss,
oder ich halte mir den Spiegel vor,
was ich mir vor 90 Tagen
vorgenommen habe.
Die Frage ist: Ist es
ein ausgeprägter Individualismus,
ein Narzissmus, ein Einsamkeits-
moment, der das beflügelt?
Kann ich in diesem Ordnungsmoment,
-system oder -wahn
überhaupt noch sozial kommunizieren,
bin ich dann
überhaupt noch erträglich
oder nur noch eine autonome Zelle,
die eine Art Selbstverwirklichung
sucht?
Ja. Da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Tanja Schindler ist mit ihrer 35-m2-
Ökominibox in Altdorf angekommen.
Sie darf sich auf dem ehemaligen
Militärgelände niederlassen.
Wieder wird das Haus alleine
auf einer grossen Wiese stehen.
Das ist überhaupt nicht ökologisch
und auch von der Raumplanung her
überhaupt nicht sinnvoll,
darum ist die Box
eben nicht fest installiert,
sondern wir wollen eigentlich zur-
zeit ungenutzte Ländereien nutzen.
Wir können hier
aber auch wieder weggehen
und das Land
ist wieder im Urzustand.
Gut so?
- Ja, hier ist es perfekt.
Die Fenster sind vorher immer
auf eine Seite gekippt.
Jetzt nimmt mich Wunder, wie es ist.
Perfekt! Jetzt ist er stolz.
Wahnsinn, echt.
Einmal abgesetzt und es sitzt.
Sonnenenergie erzeugt den Strom
und mit dem Holzofen wird geheizt.
Es ist ein von Stiftungen
mitfinanziertes Experiment
für reduziertes,
umweltschonendes Wohnen.
Ich habe eine spezielle Bewilligung,
es ist öffentlicher Grund,
wo eigentlich keine Wohnhäuser
gebaut werden dürfen.
Ich habe aber
eine Bewilligung bekommen,
weil ich ein öffentliches Projekt
bin und die Auflagen dafür erfülle,
sprich weiter Besichtigungen
zu machen.
Den Wasseranschluss und das Abwasser
musste sie allerdings
selber finanzieren,
weil das Land
noch nicht erschlossen war.
Und die neue Umgebung
hat auch ihre Eigenheiten:
Im Kanton Uri habe ich den Föhn -
er zeigt sich gleich am ersten Tag.
Davor habe ich schon Respekt.
Ich bin gespannt, wie es ist,
wenn er so richtig stark bläst.
Und sie hofft, dass sich
eine gute Nachbarschaft entwickelt,
und sie mit ihrem Lebensstil
ohne Statussymbole nicht aneckt.
Cédric Waldburger hat
in der Lounge im Flughafen geduscht
und arbeitet ein paar Stunden
zwischen zwei Flügen.
Egal wo er ist,
er ist immer total flexibel.
Das verschafft ihm auch
die grösstmögliche Übersicht
und Kontrolle über sein Gepäck -
und über sein Leben.
Meine grösste Angst ist Krebs.
Oder ganz allgemein Krankheiten,
die man nicht kontrollieren kann.
Ich habe Angst
vor dem Kontrollverlust,
den eine solche Krankheit
bringen kann.
Die Vorstellung, viel von meiner
momentanen Freiheit zu verlieren,
mein momentanes Bewusstsein
zu verlieren
oder eine Last für andere zu werden,
löst in mir tiefe Angst aus.
Im Moment fühlt er sich sehr gesund
und lebendig. Er hat sich verliebt.
(Mann) Whenever
the fasten seatbelt sign is on ...
Seine Freundin
wartet heute in Berlin auf ihn.
Schönen Tag.
Im Gegensatz zu Cédric
hat sie allerdings eine Wohnung
in der Schweiz.
Na, du?
Auch sie ist als digitale Nomadin
oft unterwegs.
Kein Wunder, wurde sie im Internet
auf ihn aufmerksam.
Ich sass zu Hause
abends auf der Couch.
Ich scrollte durchs Handy
und stiess per Zufall
bei Facebook auf ein Video.
Es tauchte in meiner Timeline auf.
Darin erzählte er
über seinen Lebensstil.
War das ein Vortrag?
Genau, es war ein Vortrag
über Minimalismus,
über seinen Lebensstil,
seine Einstellung zu allem.
Noch während ich mir
das Video anschaute, fing ich an,
Klamotten zusammenzupacken, die
schon seit Monaten bei mir rumlagen.
Aufräumen? Ausmisten?
- Ja, ich habe ausgemistet.
Dann dachte ich,
ich sollte ihn mal anschreiben,
wenn er schon nur durch ein Video
so viel Einfluss auf mich hatte,
und ich ihn
auch ganz attraktiv fand.
Ich fand an Elena sehr schön,
dass wir gleich eine Ebene hatten,
auf der wir uns super verstanden.
Beim ersten Date
kamen wir darauf zu sprechen,
was es heisst,
eine Beziehung zu haben
oder wie man es schafft, dass
eine Beziehung lange funktioniert.
Sie sagte:
"Eigentlich ist es so einfach,
man muss nur als Team denken."
"Und nicht egoistisch sein."
Dieser Gedanke leuchtete mir
sehr ein und blieb mir.
Ich wollte sie besser kennenlernen,
erfahren, was dahintersteckt,
welche coolen oder interessanten
Gedanken sie sonst noch hat.
Am gleichen Abend oder
am nächsten Morgen fragte ich sie,
ob wir uns
am nächsten Tag wieder sehen können.
So ging das relativ schnell,
dass wir uns öfter sahen.
Wir haben uns tatsächlich
schon ein paar Mal zusammengesetzt
und einige Punkte vorher überlegt,
die wir aneinander gut finden,
weiter verstärken möchten,
oder die wir am anderen als
ein bisschen problematisch ansehen,
wo wir uns helfen wollen,
besser zu werden.
Ausserdem sprechen wir
da auch über gemeinsame Ziele.
Das machen wir schon regelmässig.
Selbstoptimierung
entspricht auch ihr.
Ihre beiden Arbeitsstile
passen zusammen:
Sie optimiert Suchmaschinen.
Elena hat allerdings
alleine in ihrem Badezimmer
mehr Dinge stehen
als ihr Freund im Ganzen besitzt.
Es gab von Anfang an eine Regel:
Wenn wir zusammen
irgendwohin reisen ...
Ab und zu kommt Elena mit mir mit,
ich gehe dahin, wo sie ist,
oder wir fliegen zusammen wohin.
Ich sagte: "Wir machen das
einfach immer mit Handgepäck."
"Ich verschwende keine Zeit damit,
an der Gepäckausgabe zu warten."
Minimalist Selim Tolga
widmet sein Leben dem Aufräumen
und lebt selbst auch sehr reduziert.
Das begann bei mir bereits als Kind.
Ich räumte meine Spielsachen
gern auf,
überlegte, wie man sie
systematisch anordnen kann,
wie sie wenig Platz brauchen.
Irgendwann gab es
bei mir nichts mehr aufzuräumen
und andere fragten um meine Hilfe
beim Aufräumen des Kleiderschranks.
So wurde ein Business daraus.
Im Moment habe ich ca. 426
Gegenstände - es schwankt etwas.
Haben Sie die alle gezählt?
Ja, ich habe sogar
eine App auf dem Markt,
mit der man seine Gegenstände
pro Raum zählen kann.
Man kann einen Raum anlegen,
die Gegenstände eingeben
und kriegt dann das Total.
Das ist etwas extrem,
aber noch lustig.
Wieso nicht zählen,
wenn man nur so wenig hat.
Seine Frau
musste sich daran gewöhnen,
dass immer perfekt aufgeräumt ist,
wenn sie von ihren Geschäftsreisen
nach Hause kommt.
Dazu kommt der sog. Horror vacui.
Das Grundbedürfnis des Menschen ist,
Leere auszufüllen.
Wenn man eine Wohnung von 20 m2 hat,
füllt man 20 m2 aus.
Hat man 40 m2 zur Verfügung,
füllt man 40 m2.
Der Mensch mag Leere nicht.
Räumen Sie immer gleich alles weg,
nachdem Sie es benutzt haben?
Ja, das mache ich schon.
Es ist eine Art Aufräum-Geheimnis
oder -Regel,
alles gleich zu erledigen.
Und das Zweite ist,
dass alles seinen Parkplatz hat.
Man benutzt es
und stellt es wieder zurück.
Macht man das immer,
hat man nie eine Unordnung.
Ist es nicht zwanghaft,
alles gleich wegzuräumen?
Was ist nicht zwanghaft?
Irgendwann räumt man sowieso auf,
wieso nicht gleich,
wenn man es in der Hand hat?
Der Minimalismus
dreht sich auch um Zeitoptimierung.
Marie Kondo, ein Aufräum-Profi,
schlägt vor, die Socken
so aufzurollen und anzuordnen.
Ich mache das nicht,
aus dem Minimalismus-Gedanken -
es soll immer noch praktisch sein.
Die Socken sind alle gleich,
es ist praktisch,
sie nach der Wäsche so reinzuwerfen.
Dann nimmt man zwei heraus,
da sowieso alle zusammenpassen.
Ich versuche,
alles praktisch zu machen,
damit man keine Zeit verliert.
Die Welt ist komplex
und unübersichtlich, unberechenbar.
Ich brauche Sicherheit,
etwas, das mich rituell abholt.
Die Frage ist,
ob es eine Ersatzhandlung ist.
Indem ich mein Hemd
zu einer Wurst forme
und eine Art Wurstsalat
als Kleiderschrank habe,
kann die Welt neben mir
apokalyptisch untergehen,
aber ich habe mein System,
das mich beruhigt.
Die Frage ist, ob der Ordnungsmoment
nicht eine Beruhigungspille ist,
um mich von den wirklichen Dingen
abzulenken,
oder den Dingen, die mich oder mein
Leben wirklich verändern würden.
Ein wichtiger Prozess
als Aufräum-Coach ist auch,
dass man begleitet,
wenn es fertig es.
Hier geht es
um die Veränderung von Gewohnheiten.
Das braucht Zeit.
Ich mache Kontroll-Coachings,
schaue einmal im Monat vorbei.
So, zeig mal, wie es hier aussieht.
Brutal, schau mal.
- Das ist voll geworden.
Die leeren Ordner,
die Kisten, Möbel.
Alles eigentlich hässliche Sachen.
Gut. Wie fühlt es sich an,
wenn das alles weggeht?
Ja, die Wohnung ist jetzt leerer,
ich bin erleichtert.
Ich finde alles gar nicht so toll,
was hier ist.
Du hattest recht, Selim.
- Give me five!
Gehen wir nochmals in den Paperroom?
- Ja.
Vier Tage hat er mit ihr aufgeräumt.
Überraschung.
Danach hat sie selbst weitergemacht.
Sehr gut.
Ja.
Du bist zufrieden, oder?
- Ja.
Obwohl noch einige Dinge hier sind.
Du hättest wohl lieber noch weniger.
Das ist ein Arbeitszimmer,
das wussten wir von Anfang an.
Hier arbeitest du,
du hast deine ganzen Sachen hier.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Das sind deine Werkzeuge.
Jetzt ist alles schön geordnet.
- Das ist wahr.
Mit den Farben
hast du es schön durchgezogen,
grün und gelb,
das Bild oben passend.
Ich kämpfte um jeden Teller.
Dann sagte er:
"Du brauchst nicht so viele Teller."
Ich sagte: "Aber einen so schönen
Teller wegzugeben ..."
Plötzlich merke ich, dass ich
nicht mehr als fünf Teller brauche.
Plötzlich machtest du es selbst,
kamst rein.
Ja, ich kam langsam rein.
Ich habe Liebesbriefe weggeworfen.
Und auch schlimme Dinge -
lauter negative Briefe.
Z.B. ein Versetzungsgesuch
eines Schülers.
Ich las es wieder und er sagte:
"Das musst du nicht lesen."
"Negatives kommt sowieso weg."
Er hat mir sehr geholfen.
Eigentlich beim Aufräumen meines
Lebens, nicht nur eines Raums.
Dabei, meine Vergangenheit
aufzuräumen.
Ich habe ja
noch genug Vergangenheit hier.
Aufräumen
ist auch eine Entdeckungsreise.
Vieles kommt wieder ans Tageslicht,
man verarbeitet es
und dann kann man es
auch besser gehen lassen,
wenn man es
noch mal in den Händen hatte.
Dieses Foto liegt ihr am Herzen
und darf dort sein.
Es freut sie,
wenn sie daran vorbeigeht.
Ja, genau.
Das Wohnzimmer
ist ziemlich leer geworden.
Zeig mal.
- Ja.
Am schwierigsten war,
die Geschenke zu entsorgen.
Er schenkte mir
eine echte Straussenfeder.
Hast du Freude daran?
Ehrlich gesagt
brauche ich keine Straussenfeder.
Keine echte und keine unechte.
Aber es war ja so lieb,
ich weiss noch,
mit welchem strahlenden Lächeln
er sie mir überreichte.
Der Sinn eines Geschenkes ist,
dem anderen beim Moment der Übergabe
eine Freude zu machen.
Dann ist der Zweck erledigt.
- Aha.
Schön, wenn es so einfach wäre.
Minimalist Waldburger
ist wie immer unterwegs.
Alle 90 Tage
bekommt er von sich selbst eine Mail,
die ihn daran erinnert,
was er in verschiedenen Rubriken
ändern wollte.
Er zieht Bilanz
und formuliert neue Ziele.
Das grösste Ziel
oder die grösste Veränderung,
von der ich nicht weiss, ob ich sie
innert 90 Tagen abschliessen kann,
ist, den Wandel, den ich von
600 auf 64 Dingen vollzogen habe,
jetzt auch in meinem Kopf zu machen.
D.h. viel mehr
auf ein Projekt konzentrieren.
Als wir das letzte Mal
zusammen sprachen,
sprang ich zwischen 15
verschiedenen Projekten hin und her.
Ich hatte schon nur drei Haupt-
projekte, aber auch das ist zu viel.
Jetzt bin ich auf dem Weg, alles
auf ein Projekt zu fokussieren.
Das Zweite,
das ich im Hinterkopf habe:
Ich hatte heute vor einer Woche
einen Unfall.
Einen Autounfall,
der glimpflich ausging.
Bis auf eine Schulterverletzung
ist nichts passiert.
Aber ich hatte sicher mehr
als drei Schutzengel an diesem Tag.
Auch wenn ich mein Leben
sehr bewusst lebe,
war das noch mal eine Erinnerung,
jeden Tag zu geniessen,
aus jedem Tag
das Beste zu machen,
Dinge, die ich sagen
und machen möchte, heute anzugehen
und nicht zu verschieben.
Auch bei seiner Rubrik Liebe
hat er sehr fokussiert
eine Entscheidung getroffen.
Eine einschneidende Veränderung
oder Entscheidung meines Lebens
hat nichts mit den 90 Tagen zu tun:
Ich werde mich bald verloben.
Ich bin sehr glücklich
in der Beziehung,
weiss, dass es ist, was ich will.
Ich habe die Eine gefunden.
Dafür brauchte ich
den 90-Tage-Rückblick nicht.
Dafür musste ich nicht am Computer
sitzen und eine Mail schreiben.
Das ist tief in mir drin entstanden
und ich wusste es bald,
nachdem ich Elena kennenlernte.
Er zweifelt nicht daran,
dass sie Ja sagen wird.
Tanja Schindler
lebt jetzt seit acht Monaten
mit ihrem Ökominihaus
auf dem ehemaligen Militärgelände
in Altdorf.
Am Anfang gab es auch ein wenig
Unwillen bei den Menschen hier,
weil ich an einem Standort bin,
an dem andere
keine Bewilligung kriegten.
Ich habe eine Sonderbewilligung,
hier zu wohnen,
weil ich
ein öffentliches Projekt bin.
Mein Traum ist, dass wir
ein ganzes Dorf realisieren könnten,
um unsere Vorstellung
davon zu zeigen,
wie man natürlich, nachhaltig
und minimalistisch wohnen kann
und um die Vorteile aufzuzeigen.
Um zu zeigen,
welche Synergien mit einem ganzen
solchen Projekt möglich sind.
Da fehlt uns noch eine Gemeinde
mit einem Grundstück,
die sagt: "Wir wollen das,
wir stellen euch das
für zehn Jahre zur Verfügung."
So könnte man das wirklich testen
und Menschen, die so wohnen wollen,
diese Möglichkeit bieten.
Die Generation, die eigentlich
schon im Luxus aufgewachsen ist.
Genau sie merken jetzt ganz stark:
"Wir hatten alles und merkten, dass
uns das nicht glücklicher macht."
Wir sind die erste Generation,
die schon als Kind
immer in diesem Überfluss lebte
und der es tendenziell
immer besser ging.
Jetzt merken wir ...
... es ist nicht das.
Weniger haben, dafür mehr sein.
Ein Lebenskonzept mit Mehrwert.